bonjour marie hélène pelard merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on vient de le voir le gouvernement
peine à rassurer les parents d'élèves
mais aussi le corps enseignant qui est
inquiet c'est une attitude que vous
partagez aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait si vous voulez
l'inquiétude
elle est patent pour la journée de
demain à une rentrée on sait faire et
les enseignants se sont mobilisés pour
faire que tout se passe au mieux ce qui
nous inquiète c'est que va-t-il advenir
dans quinze jours ou trois semaines
passent conditions à un protocole
extrêmement allégées qui ne garantit pas
effectivement la sécurité sanitaire pour
les élèves et les personnels alors 53
pages de protocole qualité à respecter
pour les encadrants dans les
établissements scolaires vous le disiez
ça va être compliqué à gérer tout ça
oui oui c'est compliqué à gérer les
informations tombent au goutte à goutte
et la responsabilité revient sur sur
l'échelon local
sauf que on l'a vu on a eu l'expérience
ces derniers mois à partir du moment où
on accueille tous les enfants étant
donné qu'il n'y a eu aucune réflexion
durant l'été sur le nombre de points
d'eau sur les locaux sur le recrutement
de personnel pouvant permettre de
dédoubler des groupes
on s'attend effectivement s'il ya une
recrudescence de l'épidémie à de
nouvelles fermetures même partielles
d'école et ça on ne veut pas étant donné
qu on a eu l'expérience en mars le
distanti elle ne remplace pas l'école
pour les enfants et pour nous tout
aurait été dû être mises en oeuvre pour
que justement l'école en présentiel soit
garanti quelle que soit la situation
sanitaire
vous parlez de tout aurait dû être mises
en oeuvre mais qu'est ce qui aurait dû
être mise en oeuvre
exactement
alors on l'a vu par exemple en italie il
ya eu un recrutement massif
d'enseignants pour justement à baisser
les effectifs des classes avoir des plus
petits groupes qui permettent de mettre
en place une distanciation sociale à
l'heure actuelle moi je vais accueillir
tous mes élèves en classe ils vont être
entre 24 et 25 par classe
en l'état actuel il n'y aura pas de
distanciation physique entre les enfants
au sein d'une même classe voire même la
circulation au sein de l'établissement
va être compliqué donc on voit bien
qu'il ya des pays qui ont investi voilà
même dans le bâti pour développer le
nombre de points d'eau quand on a très
peu de robinet dans une école ça va être
compliqué on va perdre un temps dingue
alors faire laver les mains alors que
c'est essentiel justement dans les
gestes barrières et tout ça n'a pas été
fait durant l'été à la veille de la
rentrée scolaire dans quel état d'esprit
se trouve aujourd'hui le corps
enseignant est ce que est ce que vous
avez peur vous appréhender cette rentrée
écoutez c'est ses duels chose à dire on
est heureux et enthousiaste de retourner
de retrouver nos élèves et on espère que
ce soit effectivement de façon durable
et dans les meilleures conditions
possibles et vis-à-vis de notre
institution j'oserais dire avant même
qu'on reprenne ya déjà une forme de
lassitude et d'épuisement qui s'est
installée on va on va parler aussi de la
dernière sortie de du ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
bloquèrent qui promet bientôt un
grenelle des professeurs pour parler
notamment de la revalorisation des
salaires avec une enveloppe de 400
millions d'euros
un petit peu moins que ce qui était
prévu à la base 500 millions d'euros est
ce que ça vous semble suffisant
ah bah non c'est insuffisant déjà on
nous avait promis 500 millions d'euros
on tourne à 400 millions d'euros pour
quand même un grand très grand nombre de
personnels et si vous voulez on est sur
un ministre qui clame depuis trois ans
qu'il est le ministre de la
revalorisation enseignante bon dans la
réalité des faits nos fiches de feuilles
ne font que baisser et à chaque fois
qu'il ya des grandes annonces
médiatiques et des grandes promesses on
n'en voit jamais la couleur
donc tant mieux c'est un acte positif il
veut faire un grenelle concernant les
enseignants et la revalorisation
donc je voudrais dire chiche on y va
merci beaucoup maryland l'air d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin je rappelle que
vous êtes directrice d'école à l'île
saint denis et co secrétaire
départemental snuipp fsu de seine saint
denis merci beaucoup